it's the holiday season a time of year
to bring people together and to do
something a little bit different so
mythology here
I'm Matt Parker from stand up maths hey
this is Sam from Wendover productions
and half is interesting hi everyone this
James grime from the singingbanana
channel which Brady reporting for
service from numberphile objectivity and
various other channels hey everyone my
name is Steven Walsh my channel is about
slabs
I'm from the channel Looking Glass
universe grant told me he was sending me
a puzzle and a mug hey grant I am here
I've got a mug and some paper and some
markers and I'm ready to your puzzle
I really should know how to solve this
mug because I'm the guy that makes and
sells them with Matt Parker so I've been
instructed not to read the directions
before starting I've been hey grant so a
friend just gave me this mug you are
gonna be challenged and I'm just gonna
kind of make you do this on camera to
embarrass you we've got three different
houses here three different cottages and
then three different utilities the gas
the power and the water draw a line from
each of the three utilities to each of
the three houses so nine lines in total
okay without letting any to cross no two
lines crops is right here if you wanted
to just go straight from power to the
house
right okay interesting that is quits
challenge so nine lines that don't cross
that doesn't even sound possible I've
got my mug I've got my utilities mug
here I've even got real coffee in the
mug I mean that look at that that's
attention to detail I'm willing to give
this a go I'm just worried I'm gonna
muck it up I tend to make bit of a park
a square of these things when I when I
truck say well let's just fill in as
many as I can and see what happens I'm
sure this will end terribly so there's
one there's the other there we go gas
line it's gonna be easy we're gonna go
like this
Wow sound effects are crucial I'm not
gonna go around the green one don't want
to fall for that I can do another one
and now up to five four go I'm looking
at my display over here I should have
put it over there but hello oh that's
good of it that's your go to the second
is okay there's no ibly this is easy
enough and so we just need to get from
here to there I have one two three four
five six seven lines two to go so I have
that one connected to that one I mean
that one connected to that one oh now we
get into trouble okay now I start to see
the problem and there I have made my
fatal error in not paying attention
I have boxed in this house right here as
you can see there's no way to get to it
gas needs to get to number 1 and 2 and
that's the problem because we're cut off
I kind of want to try it on paper okay
it's getting really awkward to draw on a
mug I think what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna go to a piece of paper this this
kind of property that you can make lines
go from here to here and also all the
way around makes it seem like I should
be drawing a spear something like that
okay let me I need bigger lines bigger
bigger space but now I've just blocked
off how is this possible
this isn't getting anywhere let's try
again water I need to the first and
second what I really messed it up okay
to make that at least look easier I'm
gonna
go around here around around around
around around to to go around the mug
with the gas here so I'm just gonna go
all the way around I'm gonna go around
let's go underneath the handle here / /
/ / / / so now it's closed
we just need to figure out how to get
that red in there house number three is
all done and good look at that house
number three good to go so this house
has all three and that house has all
three but this one in the middle doesn't
have gas alright let me try something
new let me just try an experiment here
let's let's be let's be empirical what's
really nice about the mug is that it's
shiny so if you use a dry erase marker
you can undo your mistakes you rub it
off posit okay so there's some very
pleasing math within this puzzle for you
and me to dive into but first let me
just say a really big thanks to everyone
here who was willing to be my guinea
pigs in this experiment each of the runs
a channel that I respect a lot and many
of them have been incredibly kind and
helpful to this channel so if there's
any there that you're unfamiliar with or
that you haven't been keeping track with
they're all listed in the description so
most certainly check them out we'll get
back to all of them in just a minute
here's the thing about the puzzle if you
try it on a piece of paper you're gonna
have a bad time but if you're a
mathematician at heart when a puzzle
seems hard you don't just throw up your
hands and walk away instead you try to
solve a meta puzzle of sorts see if you
can prove that the task in front of you
is impossible in this case how on earth
do you do that how do you prove
something is impossible
for background anytime that you have
some objects with a notion of connection
between those objects it's called a
graph often represented abstractly with
dots for your objects which I'll call
vertices and lines for your connections
which I'll call edges now in most
applications the way you draw a graph
doesn't matter what matters is the
connections but in some peculiar cases
like this one the thing that we care
about is how it's drawn and if you can
draw a graph in the plane without
crossing its edges it's called a planar
graph so the question before us is
whether or not our utilities puzzle
graph which in the lingo is fancifully
called a complete bipartite graph k33 is
planar or not and at this point there
are two kinds of viewers those of you
who know about Euler's formula and those
who don't
those who do might see where this is
going but rather than pulling out a
formula from thin air and using it to
solve the meta puzzle I want to flip
things around here and show how
reasoning through this conundrum step by
step can lead you to rediscovering a
very charming and very general piece of
math to start as you're drawing lines
here between homes and utilities one
really important thing to keep note of
is whenever you enclose a new region
that is some area that the paint bucket
tool would fill in because you see once
you've enclosed a region like that no
new line that you draw will be able to
enter or exit it so you have to be
careful with these in the last video
remember how I mentioned that a useful
problem-solving tactic is to shift your
focus onto any new constructs that you
introduce trying to reframe your problem
around them well in this case what can
we say about these regions right now I
have up on the screen and in complete
puzzle where the water is not yet
connected to the first house and it has
four separate regions
but can you say anything about how many
regions a hypothetically complete puzzle
would have what about the number of
edges that each region touches what can
you say there there's lots of questions
you might ask and lots of things you
might notice and if you're lucky here's
one thing that might pop out for a new
line that you draw to create a region it
has to hit a vertex that already has an
edge coming out of it here think of it
like this start by imagining one of your
nodes as lit up while the other five are
dim and then every time you draw an edge
from a lit up vertex to a dim vertex
light up the new one so at first each
new edge lights up one more vertex but
if you connect to an already lit up
vertex
notice how this closes off a new region
and this gives us a super useful fact
each new edge either increases the
number of lit up nodes by one or it
increases the number of enclosed regions
by one
this fact is something that we can use
to figure out the number of regions that
a hypothetical solution to this would
cut the plane into can you see how when
you start off there's one node lit up
and one beaten all of duty' space by the
end we're going to need to draw nine
lines since each of the three utilities
gets connected to each of the three
houses five of those lines are going to
light up the initially dim vertices
so the other four lines each must
introduce a new region
so a hypothetical solution would cut the
plane into five separate regions and you
might say okay that's a cute fact but
why should that make things impossible
what's wrong with having five regions
well again take a look at this partially
complete graph notice that each region
is bounded by four edges and in fact for
this graph you could never have a cycle
with fewer than four edges say you start
at a house then the next line has to be
to some utility and then a line out of
that is going to go to another house and
you can't cycle back to where you
started immediately because you have to
go to another utility before you can get
back to that first house so all cycles
have at least four edges and this right
here gives us enough to prove the
impossibility of our puzzle having five
regions each with a boundary of at least
four edges would require more edges than
we have available here let me draw a
planar graph that's completely different
from our utilities puzzle but useful for
illustrating what five regions with four
edges each would imply if you went
through each of these regions and add up
the number of edges that it has
well you end up with five times four or
twenty and of course this way over
counts the total number of edges in the
graph since each edge is touching
multiple regions but in fact each edge
is touching exactly two regions so this
number twenty is precisely double
counting the edges so any graph that
cuts the plane into five regions where
each region is touching four edges would
have to have ten total edges but our
utilities puzzle has only nine edges
available so even though we concluded
that it would have to cut the plane into
five regions it would be impossible for
her to do that so there you go bada-boom
bada-bing it is impossible to solve this
puzzle on a piece of paper without
intersecting lines tell me that's not a
slick proof and before getting back to
our friends and the mug it's worth
taking a moment to pull out a general
truth sitting inside of this think back
to the key rule where each new edge was
introducing either a new vertex by being
drawn to an untouched spot or it
introduced a new enclosed region that
same logic applies to any planar graph
not just our specific utilities puzzle
situation in other words the number of
vertices minus the number of edges plus
the number of regions remains unchanged
no matter what graph you draw namely it
started at two so it always stays at 2
in this relation true for any planar
graph is called Euler's characteristic
formula historically by the way the
formula came up in the context of convex
polyhedra like a cube for example where
the number of vertices minus the number
of edges plus the number of faces always
equals two so when you see it written
down you often see it with an F for
faces instead of talking about regions
now before you go thinking of me as some
kind of Grinch that sends friends an
impossible puzzle and then makes them
film themselves trying to solve it keep
in mind I didn't give this puzzle to
people on a piece of paper and I'm
betting the handle has something to do
with this ok otherwise why would you
have brought a bug over here this is a
valid observation maybe use the mug
handle oh yeah I think I see okay I feel
like it has to do something with the
handle and that's our ability to hop one
line over the other I'm gonna start by I
think taking advantage of the handle
because I think that that is the key to
this you know what I think actually a
sphere is the wrong thing to be thinking
about I mean like famously a mug is
topologically the same as a doughnut so
to solve this thing you're gonna have to
use the torus enos of the mug you can
have to use the handle somehow that's
the thing that makes this a torus mm-hmm
let's take the green and go over the
handle here okay and then the red can
kind of come under nice my approach is
to get as far as you can with as far as
you can as if you are on a plane and
then see where you get stuck so look I'm
gonna draw
this too here like that and now I've
come across a problem because
electricity can't be joined to this
house this is where you have to use the
handle so whatever you did do it again
but go around the handle so I'm gonna go
down here I'm gonna loop underneath come
back around and back to where I started
and now I'm free to get my electricity
messy there you go and then I'm gonna go
on the inside of the handle go all the
way around the inside of the handle and
finally connect to the gas company to
solve this puzzle just drawing the M and
there's three more connections to go so
let's just make them one two and I will
have to connect those two guys right
just watch it in through the front door
out through the back door done no
intersections maybe you think that it's
cheating
well sort of topological puzzles so it
means the relative positions of things
don't matter what that means is we can
take this handle and move it here
creating another connection oh oh my god
am I done
is this over I think I might've gotten
24 minutes granny says to take 15
minutes there you go I think I've solved
it
you haven't success but but not
impossible hard but not impossible
this isn't it maybe perhaps not the most
elegant solution to this problem and if
I drew this line here you'll think oh no
he's blocked that house there's no way
to get the gas in but this is why it's
not a mug right because if you take the
gas line all the way up here to the top
you then take it over and into the mug
if you draw the line under the coffee it
wets the pen so when the line comes back
out again the pens not working anymore
you can go straight across there in and
join it up and because it wasn't drawing
you haven't had
across the lines baby by the way funny
story so I was originally given this mug
as a gift and I didn't really know where
it came from and it was only after I had
invited people to be a part of this that
I realized the origin of the mug maths
kheer is a website run by three of the
youtubers I had just invited Matt James
and Steve small world given just how
helpful these three guys were and the
logistics of a lot of this really the
least I could do to thank them is give a
small plug for how gift cards from
Matt's gear could make a pretty good
last-minute Christmas present back to
the puzzle though this is one of those
things where once you see it it kind of
feels obvious the handle of the mug can
basically be used as a bridge to prevent
two lines from crossing but this raises
a really interesting mathematical
question we just proved that this task
is impossible for graphs on a plane so
where exactly does that proof break down
on the surface of a mug and I'm actually
not going to tell you the answer here I
want you to think about this on your own
and I don't just mean saying oh it's
because Euler's formula is different on
surfaces with the whole really think
about this where specifically does the
line of reasoning that I laid out break
down when you're working on a mug I
promise you thinking this through will
give you a deeper understanding of math
like anyone tackling a tricky problem
you will likely run into walls and
moments of frustration but the smartest
people I know actively seek out new
challenges even if they're just toy
puzzles they ask new questions they
aren't afraid to start over many times
and they embrace every moment of failure
so give this and other puzzles and
earnest try and never stop asking
questions but grant I hear you
complaining how am I supposed to
practice my problem-solving if I don't
have someone shipping me puzzles on
topologically interesting shapes well
let's close things off by going through
a couple puzzles created by this week's
mathematically oriented sponsor
brilliant dork so here I'm in there
intro to problem solving course and
going through a particular sequence
called flipping pairs and the rules here
seem to be that we can flip adjacent
pairs of coins but we can't flip them
one at a time
and we are asked is it possible to get
it so that all three coins are gold side
up well clearly I just did it so yes and
the next question we start with
different configuration have the same
rules and Rask the same question can we
get it so that all three of the coins
are gold side up and you know there's
not really that many degrees of freedom
we have here just two different spots to
click so you might quickly come to the
conclusion that no you can't even if you
don't necessarily know the theoretical
reason yet that's totally fine so no and
we kind of move along so next it's kind
of showing us every possible starting
configuration that there is and asking
for how many of them can we get it to a
point where all three gold coins are up
obviously I'm kind of giving away the
answer it's sitting here four on the
right because I've gone through this
before but if you want to go through it
yourself this particular quiz has a
really nice resolution and a lot of
others in this course do build up
genuinely good problem-solving instincts
so you can go to brilliant org slash
three b1 b2 let them know that you came
from here or even slash 3 B 1 B flipping
to jump straight into this quiz and you
can make an account for free a lot of
what they offer is free but they also
have a annual subscription service if
you want to get the full suite of
experiences that they offer and I just
think they're really good I know a
couple of the people there and they're
incredibly thoughtful about how they put
together math explanations water goes to
one and then wraps around to the other
and naively at this point oh wait I've
already messed up then from there water
can make its way to cut it number three
ah
I'm trapped I've done this wrong again